hello guys my name is Asha no and
welcome to the 12th
Sparky dev vlog so it's been quite a
while since the last dev vlog and I
apologize for that but I've been pretty
busy lately and unfortunately I was
actually the funny thing is I was gonna
start this video and I was gonna be like
I don't really have much to report
that's why they haven't been dev logs
but I looked at the last dev vlog and I
looked at all the commits on github and
a lot has actually changed so I don't
even know what's going on but basically
last last dev vlog I talked a little bit
about planning and just essentially
bringing up like some cut like the
future of what I was gonna work on over
the next month or so
and then I put out a video on how to
contribute to Sparky and and since then
actually I I haven't actually realized
this but I literally have not put up a
sparky related video since I put out the
Hat to how to contribute video and a lot
of people have contributed since then so
a lot of lot of stuff has actually
happened surprisingly so I'm gonna kind
of walk through the changes I guess and
just demonstrate them to you guys and
then talk about what what I need you
guys to do and what I'm going to do over
the next week or so so let's start off
with looking at the Sparky repository we
had I think 75 commits was what it said
in the last video and there are a
hundred and two now so clearly a lot has
changed but if we go to the commits and
we go down to I think okay that's just
the way I want to do this is I'm
literally just going to look at I'm just
gonna look at the date of the April 6
was when the other one came out so it
looks like around April 6 I think I
don't know if I showed you guys this
bonds are seen I probably have actually
got this open on my own did I no doesn't
look like it I'm just going through my
previous dev vlog okay so yeah so I
guess so I'll kind of you can kind of
see who's who's been contributing to
Sparky just by reading the commits here
but clue cool I don't know how to
pronounce that added basically there's
like another test here called spawns a
test which is basically the sponsor
kind of test saying it's like a pretty
famous and never gonna render both of
them it's quite a famous little scene
that I that is pretty popular in terms
of I need to fix up some this is gonna
be real professional I need to fix up
some compilation errors okay this one's
our scene is a pretty kind of popular
graphics test that's been around for
quite a while so if we take a look at
what that looks like it's essentially
like a full kind of 3d scene so we can
probably see here that if I switch the
FPS camera this is kind of what it looks
like it's like yeah again it's like a
full 3d scene I actually added FPS
camera speed controls to the debug menu
just so that you can we can easily kind
of scale it up but yeah you can see that
we've got the respondents in this is
running in DirectX 11 here yeah and
everything's like you can control
everything as usual with that the light
direction and all that stuff aren't
there are no shadows or anything right
now and no ambient occlusion or other
kind of light things so it looks a
little bit dull but it is technically
PBR it's a little bit hard to tell but I
guess you can probably tell by the if
I'm assuming if you like if you were to
switch out the environment map it would
look quite different it's just that I
haven't been i've actually bothered to
Korean more than one environment as in
like commit or like yak read like more
than one cube map essentially for this
but anyway that's what we have here is
pretty cool that's the spawn the same so
thanks for adding that let's see I did a
bunch of stuff done I'm sure reloading
is now in DirectX this was what I this
was a demo for the cata contributor
Sparky thing the biggest thing I think
one of the biggest things that's changed
is was the official file system so I
added a virtual file system you can
probably see the beginnings of it here
or basically the way that the way that
works is that we mount certain
directories such as like for example the
models direct the models like virtual
kind of mount point is set to be this
directory which is res slash models so
you can see we have a directory in our
samples called res and then models and
what that means is that in like tests
ready or something when we load models
what we do is we actually we have a
leading forward slash then the name of
that virtual directory and then again
the actual like file name or any other
kind of folder hierarchy and what that
means is that this is now this slash
model directory is a virtual directory
meaning that you can map it to anything
right like for example if I was if I was
to change this to be something likes you
know see dev you know assets models or
something right
and I could just use false lashes if I
did something like this then that would
totally work right even like that it
would mean that we wouldn't have to
switch this out at all right it's it's
still slash models as far as all but
like as far as a client is concerned as
far as the game is concerned this slash
models is exactly what it is however you
can see that we've mapped it to
something else and you can also map
multiple you can also map multiple or
map like one mount point to multiple
directories and it'll actually keep
looking for the files until it finds one
that has the file you're looking for so
there's a few cool things you can do
with that if you guys want to check out
the code behind that of course you're
welcome to it's pretty straightforward
and I think it's too too crazy or
anything but that's kind of there now
and that that works in the future I
would like to extend this so that we can
do things like basically looking into
binary files like so essentially like a
binary blob so what that is is
essentially like you it would give us
the the possibility to have a bunch of
files or a bunch of assets kind of
squished into one large binary file and
then we could use a special file system
so the game kind of the game side looks
like it's just loading files however
they're actually located in one kind of
big file right so it's like we're
simulating a virtual file system inside
of one file
and that's something that's pretty
commonly done as well and we can just
memory map that file and then we can
kind of do a bunch of things to it
and it also means that we don't have to
distribute assets as like separate files
and there's a few benefits to that so
yeah that's kind of there are a lot of
there there are a lot of cool things we
could do with the special file system
but just being able to like map
directories like this is just the
beginning of that all right cool
yes now this was quite funny actually
the reason normal maps weren't working
in well for some reason normal Maps the
reason normal maps weren't working in
direct acts was because for some reason
we were sampling the eighth map of it
which is just read this code at all I
tried to trace it back and I actually
just couldn't so when I wrote the PBR
shader when I ported the PBR shader to
hlsl I for some reason just decided to
sample the eighth map so that was why it
was all like essentially blurry and it
appeared that it wasn't working at all
so that very weird that was that but
anyway fixed that Brotherhood of ham
huge thanks to that guy because we we
now support dynamic map generation for
2d textures in DirectX which is
something that I spent quite a bit of
time on I couldn't figure out so it
turns out that you do actually have to
basically specify every single map here
as like a separate kind of MIT little
thing and yeah it's just it's all over
the place it's a bit annoying but it is
what it is and luckily that's in there
now as you can see we have to like fully
like yeah we have to do a bunch of the
old I mean we didn't generate every
single one or anything it's just that we
this is just us working out which may
have level we want and then what else is
going on here it's been a while since I
read this card because it's like a month
old almost um actually it's more than a
month old there you go
but yeah basically we have dynamic map
gender
here and yeah we even like check check
the support for that and it's like that
so anyway or good this is now working
correctly which is why you saw it on
that sponsor scene that it looked quite
nice yes now from the VFS branch i
believe i also merged in win32
platform-specific stuff so before we
used to use yeah so we used to use if
you guys remember file utils which I
haven't deleted yet that was how we kind
of loaded strings we had no way to
relate binary files like isn't the way
that we loaded binary files was
literally just by using like file so it
was like it wasn't even through the API
or anything about us we still kind of do
that some reason actually that yeah that
should definitely be replaced well I
guess it's because we're reading out
with bye-bye-bye and so like that but
anyway this is how we used to load like
files of strings and all that stuff text
files however now what we've done
because we get a lot more control over
it is there's there's this file system
and I of course did this while I was
creating the virtual file system there's
this file system the weekend news here
which basically is like a this is a
platform independent API but what
happens is it has platform specific
implementations so for example we have
win32 file system and you can see this
actually uses Windows and it actually
probably uses the windows API to read
stuff now you might be asking why would
I write a why on earth would I write a
like a platform dependent file system or
like a platform why wouldn't I just use
like a platform independent kind of
portable file API that like say your
safe as false prophets the reason is
well there are two reasons first of all
the big one is that it just gives me a
lot more control right for example if I
want to list the files in a certain
directory if I want to see how big a
file is well how big a file is is
portable but like for example listing
files all files are located in a single
directory and all that stuff that stuff
is platform dependent right you have to
write platform dependent code for that
unless you use like some third-party
library that I guess does it for you so
we have to do this stuff anyway but also
there
is the potential for optimization
because we can control everything right
and also you have to realize that file
and I F stream or whatever under the
hood calls this code anyway right when
you when u fokin something and I love
saying fopen when u fokin something it
calls create file right that's it that's
how it works anyway so it's not like
we're doing this differently
it's just that yeah we kind of get more
fat like we get we got finer control
over how this works exactly and it again
it shouldn't be too difficult to support
to other platforms when we do that like
this took me like an hour or two
potentially to write like it was really
easy and it wasn't something that was
too difficult and again it is worth it
so anyway that's how that works and
obviously for like stuff like text files
like it's good it's good to do stuff
like this because yeah again we can and
this isn't like fully optimal yet but in
general it just gives us finer control
and you have to remember that it it ends
up like the the cross-platform stuff
ends up calling us anyway okay cool I'm
gonna speed this up because because of
reasons okay the other big thing was
font metrics right because the video
were getting too long was the reason by
the way um so yeah we had some like this
is it just an fixes files not
white-handled something close and stuff
yeah font metrics was good so we can now
see how bit like basically if we look at
and this was me fixing the ridiculous
color that there were there were
problems with her with the 2d rendering
API but basically what I added was this
stuff which was the ability to get the
offsets that like there's a bunch of
things here but for example getting the
width of a string using like from a font
the height of a string as well and the
the overall bounds of a string which is
very important because what that means
is we can measure how long help like how
big strings will be when they get
rendered and that's important because of
for example a good example of that would
be like the debug menu right so when you
activate the debug menu it measures
it creates develop menu items and then
what it does is it essentially measures
the bounds of that items label right and
by doing that by measuring the width of
the string it knows how big it needs to
create like that background so that when
we launch this so that when we launch
this and we open up the debug menu you
can see that it like it basically it
makes this like these these rectangles
in the background here exactly the right
size so that they fit like the text
right because if you if you notice
before that before that went in the only
way for us to actually like we were just
setting it like a static height and that
was it and we have like a bunch of text
bleeding over the edge and stuff like if
I put in like a really long debug menu
item such as let's just say test 3d
where do we add ones so like I let's
just say I make another one but this
one's like really long so we have dagger
gloss written twice or something and
then you'll see that the actual like the
width that debug menu becomes larger and
that's all because we can measure the
string what I'm silly let's add that
actually let's just let's just launch
test 3d because it loads quicker
where's sandbox sandbox all right test
3d here we go it still takes a while to
load
okay so that that's not even that long
this is a great demo you can see that I
really prepared for this stuff if I do
that all time professional show No
all right so this this is definitely
along strength dagger gloss Tiger glass
dango last time was alright come on
I wish I was running this in release
mode alright so you can see now that the
debug menu is very wide right so we kind
of get that positioning and of course
they're bound to the same value which is
why they're both changing but we get
that we get that that width and stuff
thanks to and of course by the way the
performance for this this debug menu is
something very wrong with well it's
something that I'm doing but anyway the
yeah you can see the width is depending
on the font metrics which is good
so that's font metrics so we can measure
stuff now which is great measure strings
yeah DirectX now prints GPU info like
the same way that OpenGL did we can
print wide chars I believe that was
important for something I don't know why
but I guess I just wanted to print that
for some reason oh yeah because some of
the stuff that we get from windows api
is like a wide chart only by the way
like I realized that in terms of strings
like I'm really only like I'm really
only like sparky at the moment only
supports one byte chars like we don't
have like utf-16 or 32 support or utf-8
kind of I guess but UTF like 16 and 32
we don't support at all which is
obviously not great we want to be able
to support those because of like let say
languages other than English but also
fonts with symbols that we may want to
use so not great that we only support
ASCII but yes appointing UTF and so like
that would be great but that's yeah
later
vsync support to Sparky so we can toggle
we can toggle vsync remember how I did
that oh yeah well in DirectX is just
presenting that thing so this is this is
great for like full-screen rendering if
you're rendering in full screen you will
notice that if you do have a sink turn
there will be no tearing whereas before
even if it was technically saying that
it was running at 60 it was fake like
limiting it to 60 so there was like a
lot of screen tearing going on so that
can now be fixed by simply enabling
vsync I also added I don't know where I
did this but so debug layer starts in
our probably oh yeah and because of four
metrics the other thing you'll notice
this is going out for a while I was
gonna a 17-minute oh my goodness
alright sorry I hate making long videos
because now I have to wait for this to
render and upload and with Australia's
internet that's gonna take a while to
upload you can see that these are like
these these stats that we have here in
the devaglia are perfectly right aligned
and you can see when the FPS increases
like above 10 like for example when I
open the debug menu um anyway ridiculous
you can see that like it doesn't it
doesn't move at all like it doesn't
before if of course it would make this
ring wire and thus it would kind of
offset this but you can see that it
actually kind of it's right aligned and
that's because that's an again another
thing that we're able to do because of
font metrics because we know how wide
the strings are which is great
built configuration platform now
available via via runtime I'm just gonna
launch test today because I'm really
getting sick of waiting for test 3d to
load this is just should be like instant
so basically the idea is that if you run
oh yeah this error I need to fix that
anyway oh yeah this this has to do with
some general studio 2015 stuff what's
this one okay lulz okay so we have by
the way these were the DirectX stats
that we print like for example the vram
as you can see there and the graphics
card okay so you can see that the title
has sandbox debug win32 written in so
the the debug win32 is the part that I
added like if we were to switch this to
release mode this is a terrible idea
because I mean oh yeah it is terrible
anyway they'll take a while to compile
well it's compiling it'll say release
win32 that's kind
point and that's easily achieved like
the way that I've done that by the way
is just by let's see so we have get
built configuration and get platformer
and essentially the platform will in in
win32 application will see VP that will
always return either will actually
either win 32 or win 64 based on certain
if stuff and then I think application
CBP must do the other one yeah so this
get built in figuration just basically
looks at the macros and yeah just sets
the appropriate one so you can see it
will be C now set to release when
officials is compiling what else fixed
solution built configurations don't
really know what the issue with that is
or what I did okay
I removed okay one of the things I did
was Festival remove 32 bit from that
from SVM build since that requires
64-bit clang or at least that's the way
I've done it so it has to be 64 because
otherwise like people getting compiler
is because they were trying to build it
and when 32 and you can't
so just to fix that up I made it
unbuildable and also I think I removed
some other stuff I'm not I don't
remember okay so anyway see how it says
release win32 yeah alright so and then I
add a continuous integration that was a
big change so basically every time okay
that's good for two reasons first of all
you can see that it verifies the master
branch so we actually try and build the
master branch if for those who we don't
know if those of you who don't know what
continuous integration is basically
every time the code changes there's a
there's like a there's like a server
which does a full clean build of the
visual studio solution or like you know
of the whatever of the project and and
essentially you see any errors and all
that stuff and the idea is right now you
can see it's building both debug and
release configs
and anyone can view this by the way this
is the log for that so AB fááááá up
there is like a little
it's like kind of like trap there's
another one called Travis which is good
for like Mac and Linux stuff however if
you want a you know a Windows build so
if you want to build this using em SVC
which is the visual studio compiler then
obviously this one's like the only one
I've found that's free as well because
you can see this will use msbuild - yeah
here it is - just build the solution
which is fantastic and then you can see
this took like four minutes so it's not
particularly slow and yeah essentially
this was successful right so it just
verifies that there are no kind of build
errors at four it'll do like all
configurations debug and release and
then of course the idea is we have
continuous integration for all platforms
right now we're on the support window so
we only have this but in the future
we'll have it for all platforms which is
good because it means that like
occasionally something that you change
in Visual Studio will compile fine and
in you know the visual studio compiler
in MSV C but it won't work in clang or
like JCC or something not that I don't
think will support GTO J plus plus at
all really I think clang is probably the
only one but anyway it won't like it
won't compile it'll be fine in like
Visual Studio in fact it'll be fine in M
SBC but not in clang and we get all
those kind of errors it's obviously
easier to just kind of commit this and
see if it fails rather than testing it
on like all compilers and stuff actually
you really should test it on all
compilers I'm just being lazy and that's
how I usually do stuff I just commit it
and see what happens but anyway that's
naughty don't do that test it properly
but that's also good for caching arrows
also you can get to commit binaries for
you I haven't had the time to set that
up but basically once it does
successfully build something it can
it'll commit fresh binaries to the bed
folder that way you never have to commit
binaries in fact you can see I've kind
of stopped community wineries because
it's just too hard to maintain like I
don't really feel like doing it and
neither does anyone else really so the
cool thing is the build machine or the
like the continuous integration once it
does build those binaries it can commit
them and push them so yeah that's the
idea behind continuous integration so
now we support that there's a little
advert
the animal kind of file which just has
the kind of what I want to do I get an
email every time something happens I'm
going to turn that off because the other
reason that this is really useful by the
way is that everyone who commits stuff
I'm sorry everyone who opens a pull
request it actually verifies as you can
see it all checks yeah here we go it
verifies continuous integration you can
see it actually tries to build that so
basically I know whether or not your
code compiles so you can see like for
example this code does not compile and
if you do open a pull request once a lot
of myths if you do open a pull request
and you see that your continuous
integration has failed you can look at
details and you can look at the log and
see why failed right one thing I've
noticed and you can see this person's
just looks like and this is like almost
identical to Visual Studio output which
is great because it's really easy to
read speaking of which where are those
arrows at broseph
okay here we go so like math func is not
a class namespace name blah blah
sometimes I wonder how people can get
these errors here like I'm assuming you
guys compile your code before you commit
it there anyway
um the idea is that you can look at your
you can basically see if your thing is
working or not and if it's not then you
can fix it obviously I'm not gonna merge
the stuff that breaks the build the
other thing is this is also nice because
I was gonna say actually the other thing
that people tend to forget is like on
this continuous integration they will
like it'll compile like on debug like if
they add if people add new projects or
they like modern or make changes to
project configurations they only test
debug right the idea is you have to make
sure those compiles in debug and release
we don't care round em scripting I
really should remove that for now at
least
but debug and release win32 and
potentially in the future x64 I'm in
fact soon because tools are probably
only going to be x64 I and the runtime
will be both x64 and win32
you need to make sure that the code that
you've written and the changes you've
made work for all configurations right
just debug is obviously not good enough
and it to work for both so that's why
this is great because it lets you unless
me you'll really quickly see you can see
the like the failures and the passes
here which is fantastic and I really
need to merge some of these okay and
then that's it so we have a status batch
now as well you can say that it says
whether all the builders passing this is
just for the master branch
there's build passing things so this
should always be passing master should
always be building correctly there's no
excuse really for not to be all the
other branches don't really care about
them a lot of them are kind of
intermediate branches I've been using
for work so like every time I commit
like a lot of that stuff is working
progress most of it should compile but
sometimes it might not so whatever we
don't care about that master is the
branch that is like our publishing kind
of branch ok cool that that that is
about the end of that I do want to say
that in terms of what we're working on
this week and again this is a huge
devlog I guess it's been in it's been
like a month since the last one so fair
enough I guess but the things that I'm
working on so the CLI they still I
generated tool i I do want to do that
still obviously but I actually want to
write a CLI manually first CLI of course
being that the intermediate kind of link
that we have between the C++ and C sharp
code so it's like I managed kind of
binding for Sparky's API so that we can
use it in c-sharp the reason I want to
write it manually first is primarily
said that I know what to generate
because I got to a point in the CLI gen
stuff and you can actually look at that
CLR generator by just going to the CLI
gen branch and it'll be in Tools CLR gen
right this is the actual you know code
for that there's a bunch of stuff here
but the idea is that yeah and you can
see that what it does like it literally
just outputs code like it did this
writes code for us so that we don't have
to did we'll be able to order
automatically wrap stuff so you can see
like a bunch of stuff going on here like
hash include' names for ssbns passive
CLI like there's a bunch
it's pretty cool it works reason like
it'll generate like empty it'll it kind
of works in a way like it doesn't
support advanced things like well
there's a bunch of stuff it doesn't
support for example it like inheritance
and stuff like that it'll share you with
but there's a bunch of stuff that it
does support and it will eventually work
I just need to actually write it myself
first so that I know what to generate
but basically I'm gonna push this this
is this is gonna be on a branch called
CLI right so not CLI Jen just CLI and if
you guys you feel like learning how to
write C++ CLI code and you want to
contribute to this because all this is
is just wrapping code so you can see
that for example we have say like the
constructor for application and we have
like this virtual void in it void star
suspend resume and what that translates
to and we find a good example for you
guys because I'm not finding any good
ones
I think window is alright yeah weird is
pretty good so you can see that like
window dot edge for example only the
public stuff we care about public and
protected we obviously don't care about
private stuff because that we don't need
to expose that to co-op because it's
private anyway you know we have all
these methods that we write here and
then all it does is you can see like
it's a wrapper it just calls stuff
occasionally you have to do conversions
like for example for strings and like
for arrays as well you'll have to do
conversions so of course set title calls
the actual kind of one inside win32
window that'll because it'll call the
one in window which takes is like an STD
string and we give it a system string
which is a c-sharp string and we have
like conversions between those things
and anyway the idea is that this code is
kind of easy to write it doesn't take a
genius to write it there are some
certain hard parts and you can see that
I've got like this is like shaders for
example here we have pin this is old
code this is from the old Sparky CLI
stuff but I started updating it now and
hopefully we can have a complete binding
for c-sharp just by writing all this
code so if you guys want to help out on
that it's not particularly difficult
it'll be great for you guys because
it'll you'll learn essentially a new
language called C++ CLI you can always
ask me questions on slack if you need
help this is a great time to
promote slack as well I've got a slack
team there's a Sparkie channel I'm
active here all the time you can see me
replying to people exhibit a but you
know hang out here if you want to
contribute especially but yeah just if
we could get some people working on this
it'd be fantastic and of course you guys
will probably learn something new such
as C++ CLI and we'll get some it's
wrapping code done because I really
don't have the time to do this and I'd
rather work on kind of harder things um
but we do need to get this stuff done
so if you're looking for so if you were
like thinking about contributing Sparky
but afraid that like I don't know how to
do this this is a great little thing to
do because there's a lot of it's really
simple so if you want to work on it one
of the one of the things that I'm afraid
of and that has been happening to an
extent is people like multiple people
working on the same thing obviously this
wouldn't happen if we were like in a
actual team you know physically but you
know to make sure that you're not
working on something that other people
are working on you should just kind of
either open an issue here and say hey I
want to work on this and I like whilst I
can't really assign you to it
I can unofficially assign it to you and
just kind of be aware that people will
like for example this person clearly has
been like I like this guy is a fantastic
example actually I forgot about this
this person here our it's hack is a Ritz
hack I guess is is working on a Linux
build for Sparky right and I mean look
at this like this is better than some of
the stuff that I've written for like
work and stuff like this is like you
know what there's a checklist here like
intentions progress note like this is
actually really really nice so you can
see like and he's had like a bunch of
questions right that I've happily
answered like and just you know opening
a dialogue like this is really really
good and you know just being like hey
I'm gonna work on CLI I'm gonna work on
you know making sure that for example
everything in graphics is going to be
CLI does anyone want to take a look at
events and all like or the audio name
face and maybe start rapping that code
and you know you feel free to
collaborate and yeah and really just
help out with this because it's
something that like I know a lot of
people asking me hey is there anything
specific you want help with apart from
maybe looking at issues and seeing like
you know oh I can take a look at
post-processing effects even though I've
like obviously if I'm assigned to it it
means I'm working on it so I don't want
other people working on earth and that's
actually kind of almost done I think
there's a post effects branch attached
to render targets is actually that
branch I believe yeah added post effects
so there's a bunch of stuff going on
that I'm working on as well that's the
other thing actually post effects kind
of work so much stuff this project is
out of control but basically I need your
help so if you want to help out with
this CLI is a really good thing to help
out with it'll be on the CLI branch just
start opening pull requests with stuff
that you do I'll definitely merge them
and make some issues setting your
intentions and the fact that you're
working on something and yeah let's all
do this together and it'll be great
okay so that's going to wrap up this dev
vlog that's huge just some final things
to leave you guys with obviously if you
haven't checked out the repository do so
and don't forget to star the repository
we're approaching 500 stars soon which
is pretty cool and the other thing is if
you want to support Sparky and you just
can't contribute or you don't want to
contribute or you want to extra support
Sparky then you can pledge any amount on
patreon and this just helps me out by
allowing me to set more to essentially
set more time aside for working on
Sparky so if you want to support us
Marquis development and and help me out
then this is a great place to do so
alright guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this dev vlog please hit like
button went on for quite a while
hopefully I'll see you next week with
another dev vlog I think I'll go back to
I took a little bit of a bit of a break
but I think I'll go back to weekly dev
logs again and yeah thanks for watching
I'll see you next time goodbye